greetings from podcast Ville its Monday
the 3rd of February who the [ __ ] you
think it dealing with January is done
kick this [ __ ] melee there ain't
no mule to kick how you guys doing
it's February the 4th it's a beautiful
day to be alive no guests today we're on
the solo tip it's a first podcast or a
month and I want to talk to you people
about something you know sometimes I
look at the [ __ ] town and I remember
things like sometimes like today is my
best friend lube his birthday
I called him already in an answer
[ __ ] today's awesome my daughter's
birthday she turns 30 [ __ ] years old
and it was weird that yesterday I was
doing paperwork or whatever and I
noticed it was February 2nd and I'll
never forget that date because that's a
date I got in a halfway house but that's
a dinner that's the first time I really
lived life with responsibility you know
I got a lot of emails from you guys
every week and you're going through
whatever you're going through I want you
to I want you to know something man the
20's a [ __ ] throw away is at the end
of the game they don't even count I sit
here at 57 in two weeks I'm telling you
that your 20s
don't even [ __ ] matter you're gonna
[ __ ] up you're gonna lose job you're
gonna get fired you're gonna switch
careers you're gonna get engaged you
know you know everybody falls in love
just you know we do just [ __ ] dummy
things that could define who you are for
the rest of your life or yeah cause
that's what you're gonna do you're gonna
make a mistake or do something good
that's going to define your life with my
situation I got a felony it didn't
define who I became I also got I had a
baby that defined who I became because I
failed as a father the first time around
but let's get to this February 2nd
February 2nd 1990 I had been putting
that I had been released from the
halfway house and put back two times on
probation violations because I couldn't
keep it together
I just could not keep it together I'm a
doggie language like a [ __ ] poster
child the difference between me and
Artie at the time was that there was
more ways to scam the system now they
got you they got young computer with
bracelets that the only not to piss test
you they take a hair out of your [ __ ]
hair and they check your follicle yeah
you know they swab a [ __ ] thing in
your mouth like you can't beat half this
[ __ ] I was doing but I was just like
when I was watching already going
through his thing I first of all he came
up on a year anniversary a day and I was
so [ __ ] a happy family
because he went through the hardest year
of his [ __ ] life once you got a beat
the first year he trust me the
percentages go down and down and down
and down and hopefully you know he'll
see the other side of the fence and you
go for life the same way I did you know
once you see the side of the fence
it's tough listen I'm wrong people do
coke if you don't think I'm around
people who do coke you're out of your
[ __ ] mind
I've been on the road with people who
are doing color it doesn't affect me it
doesn't make me want it you know it's
like my Joey karate videos once I was
done with him I was [ __ ] done with
them I don't go backwards and up you
know it doesn't affect me at all but
back to the 2nd of February 1990 mmm my
wife at the time picking me up she was
nine months pregnant she was due any day
there wasn't like a due date they think
the due date was like the 10th or some
[ __ ] and I remember her picking me up
when I got in the car and slammed that
door
I remember saying like a couple things
to myself this is the last time I'm
coming back this halfway house and I'm
about to have a kid
which means life is gonna get [ __ ]
real and I know two people who are going
through a lot right now the church
family not that I call it or anything I
mean they're going through fatherhood
for the first time you know Scott
Cunningham and and Michael Kline you
know one by one podcast great guy you
know yeah they called I still gonna call
him Micah two in the [ __ ] morning
I'm answering you know the and I called
me then answer and right away he hit me
on Twitter he was I couldn't answer I
was putting the baby to sleep you know
things happen do you think Michael
really wanted to put the baby to sleep
that night you know I'm saying so when I
got out of the halfway house I knew
right away that day I had to changed my
whole [ __ ] life and I was like this
is just not gonna work and you know guys
I'm the biggest procrastinator there is
like I'm the type of guy that I'll tell
you for a year I'm doing something I'm
like I got I put myself in wars
positions than you guys could ever even
dreamed up because I don't know if it's
on the nice guy or sometimes I'm a [ __ ]
but sometimes you tell somebody gonna do
something and as the date gets closer
you really realize you don't want to do
it that's okay if you're going through a
concert that's okay if you don't want to
go on a trip but it's not okay if you're
gonna have a baby it's not okay if
you're gonna get married it's not okay
if you quit your job high-ranking
[ __ ] job to take a low-ranking job
and and it's not what you ended up
thinking you know once you make career
decisions like I'm one of those guys
like I got married and I realized on the
[ __ ] plane on the honeymoon that I
didn't want to be married too [ __ ]
late now you know it's too [ __ ] late
Joey when I got when I got a little
[ __ ] a halfway house and she picked
me up like I was seeing her every day
but when I looked at her at lunch that
day and we were back and she took his
shirt off I'm like this chick is big I'm
about to be a [ __ ] father I don't
know if I'm into all this [ __ ] I lost
the next morning that night we went to
Lucille's that place I told you about
mold that has occasion food that's a
[ __ ] delicious and I had like the
black and red fish with this bayonets
and this [ __ ] the spicy Louisiana
sausage and my wife ate the same and we
went back I couldn't get high like refi
so I it was snowing and I [ __ ] passed
and I [ __ ] was so tired I was so
stressed about life we must have passed
on a tool on the afternoon and just
slept all day like we both just [ __ ]
slept all I remember is her waking me up
telling me her water broke and it's you
know when you have this think of of
prison on you guys you can't not dis
growling right now because of the
Internet
you get to watch people unwind you get
to see something somebody says it does
and then two weeks later they do some
Mouse and two weeks later they do some
Mouse then they get thrown off with her
then I get thrown off voice book
Facebook then they get thrown off
Instagram and you just see it you know
you see what Alex Jones you see it with
rum Rush Limbaugh without boy with the
edible you just see it with different
people you know like they start the
[ __ ] deteriorate little by little I
don't even know we're talking about the
but that's you were talking about how
you all she woke you up and you had the
stink of prison onion yeah like I just
had the stink of prison on him once you
have the stink of prison on you that
means you're gonna have police contact
no matter what you do really like I had
police contact a little bit too this way
I had police contact January 29th or 28
1983 that was the first real time I got
pinched for possession of of burglary
tools like stolen property and then
after that I had police contact but I
didn't get arrested like I would have
police contact in time to time but I
wouldn't get arrested and I got pinched
in New York with a bag of weed like a
year later again I would have police
contact but I wouldn't get pinched
what's police contact this guy said he
robbed his house this guy said he you
know I police contact there's a
[ __ ] once you get the stink of
police contact on you you can't get it
off you
so let me give an example my my war my
wife's water breaks now we had a condo
we bought a condo we rented a condo in
that complex first and then I swindled a
condo other one of the [ __ ]
counselors at the halfway house
I caught him one of the other counselors
and I tormented him and when he quit his
job I swindled the Mike [ __ ] some 500
down two hundred a month type condo deal
then the lady who owned the condo called
it was too late like it was [ __ ] up so
I moved into this condo without knowing
that the guy downstairs from me was
[ __ ] crazy like he would stay up all
night I would hear music and falling the
more like you know I would get up to get
something to drink as its drying
Colorado and I would hear music and all
this [ __ ] he would talk to himself and I
found that he was like a meth head
somebody told me like one of the
neighbors said that guy stays up every
night people bring him back in jizz and
he just walks around and [ __ ] and he
would always throw away boxes of puzzles
saves me down there for them to puzzles
Rylan I'll [ __ ] along on the met I
don't know I don't I didn't know the guy
all I know is that my wife must have
made a noise that made this guy called
9-1-1 like I was beat so I had to go you
know I come outside it's no [ __ ] 8
inches of snow so I gotta go outside now
and clean off the car and while I'm
cleaning off the car I see two two cop
cars coming down the street it wasn't
really the street it's like a parking
lot
indeed another for you not an idea okay
I'm like what the [ __ ] wants to happen
and all of a sudden the cops are like
they get out they're like put your hands
on the car and I'm like okay and I put
my hands in the car and I go what's
going on they're like turn around they
came up to me they frisked me and they
handcuffed me and then they ran into the
house because the front door was kind of
open and they knocked me go hello hello
my wife
hello and and then like a you okay and
my wife was in the bedroom on the bed
waiting for me to come pick her up and
they're like hey you injured and she's
like what are you talking about and he
goes they with the cop goes we just had
a domestic violence call from here and
she goes no my water broke and I was
telling my husband to hurry up he's
outside getting the car ready
but that [ __ ] method called the cops
on so the cops help me carry her out to
the [ __ ] car we put her in the front
seat one cop car got in front of me I
got behind the one cop car the cop car
got behind me and we [ __ ] sped off to
the [ __ ] to the hospital it took us
like eight minutes it wasn't cool cool
was [ __ ] Here I am a convicted felon can
the police escort to the [ __ ]
hospital I get there we go through the
whole [ __ ] thing she has the baby
like that morning like at 12 or
something - and finally at 6 our home
and even though I was in the halfway
house I had to celebrate so sure enough
he had an 8 ball
I called my brother-in-law her brother
and we did a [ __ ] eight-ball and thank
God my number didn't come up that
[ __ ] mundane I'd have to pee in a
bottle well they would have put me right
back on the [ __ ] a halfway house I
mean you know you know me dawg I told
you I made all these language
like while you're doing it or you looks
like [ __ ] it [ __ ] it
alright they're not gonna piss me I'll
beat the test you know your addiction
just convinces you then you're you're
this superhuman guy and then when you
come down and you got your pressure like
what am I gonna do now now I got to pray
for Monday that my colour doesn't come
up when I say color is on Mondays from 1
to 5 12 to 5 you had a koala number and
I think my number was my color was no
room okay and they'll tell you the
colors for the day are black white
purple you have four hours to report
please leave a message so you had a leak
you had a call every Monday Wednesday
and Friday leave a message
to let them know that
called if he didn't call it was a
probation violation if he doesn't leave
a message and we were close to going
back to prison for another violation
oh yeah violation is 90 days but in the
halfway house it could be in County Jail
it could be in jail it could be at the
halfway house and I always had a
so-called important job
my attorney always mr. Diaz and once I
started wearing this suit that's why I
started selling cars in there - guys
were in a [ __ ] suit okay he must do
something that's important even when I
wasn't someone cause I was thrown
putting the suit on to leave they
thought I was selling cars
I really wasn't selling cars you know
but it's so weak so that Monday you're
supposed to call so four people don't
know what I'm talking about that's what
it was then which is 30 years ago I
don't know what this done I just must
knock on your house and pull your
[ __ ] hair on the head and tell you
tested positive for heroin I'll know
what it was then but now but this is
what it was then and you know and I kept
throwing I kept gone and gone and going
until yeah I'm so finally 18 months
later she smartened up and said this
marriage isn't gonna work but the funny
thing was that and I don't know how to
say this to you guys like I was not
happy in my situation like when we and I
don't want you to think that I'm saying
I didn't love the baby or anything like
that
I just didn't take for the situation how
I thought I would and looking back at it
now I felt very bad about it for years
and I see my treatment of mercy now and
I know that the reason why I was acting
the way I was before was because of my
addiction like now that I'm sober with
mercy I see where the shortcomings I
didn't fail as a father I was just on
[ __ ] drugs how much of it do you
think is the drugs worse like that cuz
you you started this off saying like
your 20s are crazy like how was it a mix
of everything or was it like all I
wasn't ready yeah some people are not
ready you're not mature enough I'm sorry
I wasn't
sure enough at 20 [ __ ] seven to have
a child I just wasn't mature enough I'm
sorry to say that that's just boy life
is some people mature you know I know
people like kids at 18 made it work for
themselves and got jobs and you know did
whatever I just wasn't mature enough I
didn't know what I had on my hands I
didn't really know the responsibilities
of what you have on your hands I didn't
know that the decisions that I made
affect everybody in my [ __ ] family I
had no idea you don't know these things
of 20 [ __ ] 7 you know nobody told you
these things you learn these things as
you [ __ ] go along with it you know
but it's it's I loved her I took care of
her hurry sadly you know I took care of
my change the diapers there was no drama
there
it wasn't the happiness that I have
today my mind was always somewhere else
even though I loved her and then we got
separated and you know again that's
where that statement comes in you don't
know what you got to you lose it and
then I really wanted to be close to her
but it was too late she didn't want me
to have a relationship with her I knew
this since day one you know like this is
I don't know what you people know all
the story this is the last one our
one-man show I did was about that time
period from 93 to 95 and it took me a
long time to read like I have a month
and between one-man shows to write a
section and this one I wrote every
[ __ ] day and I had a hard time
writing at every [ __ ] day because I
didn't know how I could explain myself
of my actions at this time but to start
the thing off I had to remember
something that she had said to me like
we broke up in October 15th of 1991 we
separated by February of 92 I knew I
wasn't gonna be that
kid's father for much longer like I
didn't need to have a crystal ball she
did something that people never
understood why I got so angered of I'm a
very old-fashioned type of guy Lee and
life things happen and for the people at
home things happen in life and things
are gonna happen to you
and things are gonna happen that you're
gonna have to say that somebody
something happened then just happen in
life you know you you you you get
married you have a child you go to work
you meet a co-worker you and her hit it
off I'm not saying that you're cheating
or whatever but sometimes in life love
comes at a weird time things happen in
life you know you you realize the person
you're with is not who you want to be
with you want to be with this person
eventually you cheat and it's not about
the sex you really enjoy being with that
person I would you know whatever the
[ __ ] happens things happen you're not
gonna fall in love forever you know
things happen in life that people have
to accept that that comes a day that
sometimes but one day my wife might come
home and tell me she's not in love with
me no more and you have to accept these
things you could throw a couple of
mirrors and yeah you're gonna go back
you're gonna go out and have a couple
beers and you're gonna go to walk to
your friend's house and talk for them
but the quickly you accept it so quickly
you can move on to your next chapter
well it was interesting when we were
talking about how like the dear 20s is a
throwaway and then you said how you
realized you didn't want to be married
on the flight and where I was thinking
is and it's something that I struggle
struggle with it's like you you said oh
it's too late now
but in reality you could have just been
like hey we both know this is like you
could got an annulment
like sometimes like that's what I've
learned recently is you sometimes you
can just make the decision and it's not
gonna be as bad as you think it's gonna
I knew that June that June of 91 I knew
our relationship was over
okay I knew something wasn't
right I was working too much I was
working on purpose I'm the laziest man I
was working five days a week from my
brother-in-law roofer
I was working six nights a week as a
doorman deejay bar back and I was
working two days a week on my own
private little roofing jobs I did not
want to be home okay that's a problem
when you have a child and you don't want
to be home when I was home I was happy
to see the child with the child
I bathed her and I did everything I was
called upon to do on Saturdays if I
didn't work like sometimes on Saturdays
I would go my wife would cut hair and I
would have the baby on Saturday and I
enjoyed it I had no problem with that I
liked everything about it I just wasn't
prepared to do it full [ __ ] time like
I just you know I had addiction on my
mind that partying on my mind and then
cheating on my mind that was not in my
mind at all you know when when I came
home October 15th and she said to me she
didn't want to be with me already I had
caught in the bug of comedy I was trying
to get out of all this as it was I was
like how am I gonna get to do [ __ ]
comedy with everything I have going on a
child to read Jobs a [ __ ] wife well
okay I don't even have a wife the only
glue in this house was that child you
know that was the only thing that was
keeping us [ __ ] together on the
weekends I'd do a little bit of coke
like on Friday nights and I wasn't
getting caught and eventually I got I
got signed off Community Corrections and
you know things worked out the way they
did but she did something that really
aggravated me was that if she woulda
came to me listen man I've learned over
the last 20 years how to talk to pee
I really have I didn't know how to talk
to people I was always very scared of
talking to people and then one day one a
couple weeks around I make a very hard
decision something I've been bothering
me for six months and I had to make a
hard decision and I knew and October I
had to do it and I woke up January 21st
and that's how long it took me to make
the [ __ ] decision that's how long a
procrastinator I am but when I did it I
did it I'm not looking back you know I'm
not looking back with my wife I was too
young I was like I guess this is what
happens when you get married you get
married you hate the person but just
staying together because of the kid what
what a [ __ ] miserable [ __ ]
existence you know the jobs I had I love
doing them I was good at estimating I
was good as a labourer I was good as a
[ __ ] door guy I was good as a sound
guy I was good as a barback when I was
working at that comedy club but there
was none of those jobs I really wanted
to do was a living I wanted to give
comedy a [ __ ] try you know I really
really wanted to give it a [ __ ] try
and even though the first two years it
was like I was just getting to find who
the [ __ ] I was when I look back at it
now it was fine
that was fine there was a that was
exactly I was supposed to be doing that
looking for a voice meeting people
getting different advice and bad comics
and some good comics you know cuz you're
getting advice and bad comics you giving
advice good comics you get an advice
from many of the comics you getting
advice from corporate comics you get
advice from clean Commerce you get
advice from dirty comments you're
getting all this advice you're getting
all this [ __ ] thrown at you and you have
to figure out where you're picking you
know there's a lot of guys that say well
I'll do this but I'll work on this and
then I'll have a Tonight Show set now
dude no I knew at one point I had to
make a decision what direction I was
gone and once I made that direction two
and a half years I went with it
and then it was the experimenting
remember I told you I wore a suit for a
year and I bombed every time you know I
wore a suit for a year to try to look
nice I've combed my hair I put on a
collared shirt on I put a tie on I'd
loosened the tie I tried to close the
tie I bomb
I opened the collar I bombed you know as
long as I had a [ __ ] suit on I
thought I was a bombing machine so when
I took the [ __ ] shoot off and put
jeans on the t-shirt I started getting
them [ __ ] I started to all the suits
away it was a process it was really a
[ __ ] process that never ended you
know but you weren't charged oh well do
you feel more control of it
every day that I fell in love with it
every failure that I had made me fall in
love with it
remember you can't move forward without
having failures it's just impossible
it's impossible I heard yesterday during
the Super Bowl that one of those guys
that made all those great plays and now
he's on the Kansas City San Francisco I
don't know they said that he had been
cut by seven teams yeah it was okay had
been cut by seven teams if you get cut
by four teams where's your ego at seven
teams he got caught by seven [ __ ]
time somebody told him that what he had
to offer wasn't good enough for that
team what do you think that guy felt
like and now he's in a [ __ ] Super
Bowl and he made a tremendous play and
they talked about him getting cut seven
[ __ ] times what does that tell you
that's a certain that takes a certain
guy after four times I'm like [ __ ] I'm
getting a job in a warehouse this isn't
working off of me but do you think its
genetic or is it learned like there are
like you're I think you're one of those
people who has and it's not even working
I think well it's it's it's like the
you're strong enough mentally to push
through it there's some things I'm not
like I look there's some failures
they'll just take you look [ __ ] like
what like what like that
I'm always impressed with people who can
bounce back my basketball failing me
quitting back listen I quit everything
that I ever tried I'm a [ __ ] quitter
I quit everything
I quit the electrician's Union I quit
bullyin longshoremen I quit being a
[ __ ] hottie I quit being a [ __ ]
painter the one that killed me the most
was basketball high school the high
school one that killed me the most you
know when I was dragging the dirt over
my mom's that my father's dead and all
that [ __ ] part of the death I was
carrying was the death of me walking
away from basketball I didn't know how
much it devastated me
until about 20 years ago that devastated
me that made me become a different
person that made me I wasn't angry I'm
not gonna lie the I was I was angry at
the coach that [ __ ] my freshman year
right
until this day people will tell me that
he [ __ ] you he [ __ ] on purpose he
was waiting to [ __ ] you you know but he
[ __ ] me in a way that it really
affected me for 20 years
I wanted to stab him I thought about you
know going I knew a barrio not North
Bergen
I knew 20p but I didn't like the guy he
would have been lazy bottle over the
head to break and the cops on the cam
and whatever but the last 15 years I
loved them 40 then because he put a
thorn in my side and that thorn stayed
in there for a long [ __ ] time it
stayed in that till I was 33 years old
from the time I was 14 so what was the
thorn look waiting or the fact that he
didn't like the thorn in my side was
that I let him beat me and I was not
raised to let somebody beat me
especially mentally if somebody's 650
or to 80 23 years old they're gonna beat
me up I'm 57 years old even when I was
21 if you were 6 foot 4 to 80 you were
gonna beat me up
yeah but I let him beat me mentally
I met I let him beat me to the point
that I quit there was a movie that came
out in 1977 it was on a couple of weeks
ago it's called one on one with Robby
Benson and it's about a college kid a
high school star that goes to a big-time
college and he just starts to fall
through the cracks the style of
basketball that he was designed to play
that's now or wasn't the curriculum at
the school so the coach came to him one
day and said I want you to renounce your
scholarship and he told them I'm not
doing it I don't care what he put me
through and the coach put him through
[ __ ] hell the coach would have him
fouled he would have tough guys they
broke his nose they took away his
[ __ ] scholarship money they took away
his booster money they took away
everything from this [ __ ] kid but
they didn't take his [ __ ] balls away
so he got two jobs and he practiced
basketball all [ __ ] night you know
he'd play basketball on them one day he
was on the team two guards got hurt and
they put him in and the ended up winning
the game and then they and they were
stealing at the end of the [ __ ] well
I think the movie the coach calls him
into the office and the coach goes I'm
very proud of you because you didn't
listen to what I told you to do well we
ended up one of the [ __ ] game and he
goes I'm very proud of you and he goes I
just want you to know you're gonna have
your scholarship back and he tells them
what the guy told him he goes up your
ass with a red-hot poker
I could play anywhere the [ __ ] I want
now [ __ ] [ __ ] you and he walks out of
the guy's office oh [ __ ] you know he
didn't let that guy be the mentor
he let the guy beat him take away his
job you could do anything you want to me
but you're not gonna beat me mentally I
let that guy get inside my head and made
me quit something I love doing that till
this day I love doing I don't have the
capabilities to do it anymore
I can't shoot on my shoulders but if my
shoulders were fine I'd probably be
playing in an over-50 league right now
even if it was three on three half-court
basketball wow I was that good as a
basketball player and my friends will
tell you when you see them I was that
good as a basketball player I mean when
I got to my sophomore year I realized I
was fired for ten I looked at my mother
she was fired for four and I looked at
my father he was six before I lived the
rest of my family and they were all on
the five feets you know what was I gonna
do what was I I had good legs I could
jump I could grab the rim while I was in
the eighth grade but that wasn't enough
to get me a scholarship at least I
didn't think so
what that wasn't it I just quit because
he cracked me I let him [ __ ] crack me
so looking back well do you wish you'd
come back sophomore year and try it
again or I wish I wouldn't have quit
school and I should have played even if
i sat the bench even if I set the match
my problem was I realized too soon as I
did the biggest mistake I realized too
soon I wasn't gonna get nowhere
so I did what most people do they quit
that's I'm never gonna get to that point
so I'm gonna quit you know what I was
good enough to play all four years like
I wouldn't have started varsity my
senior year I was ass at the bench I
would have been like number 12 but I was
still but on varsity right
okay I'm saying like I wasn't that good
to start I didn't have the body to start
no it's it's tough it's tough to jump I
could rebound well I could do all you
had a place on team huh you would have
had a place I would have a place in the
team I wouldn't have been the star I
wouldn't have been
all state I wouldn't have been I
wouldn't have gotten a scholarship to
basketball I would have just called what
people called let it and for me I didn't
wanna let them so I said [ __ ] it I'm
quit that's the easiest [ __ ] solution
so when I got you know I tell people
this all the time I didn't get I got
into comedy to become a man I didn't get
into college to become a comic I came
into comedy to become a man because at
some point you have to become a man when
you do this you have to be responsible
you have to go above and beyond you know
I'm doing comedy 20 years [ __ ]
Saturday I went to kick boxing I had to
go to two parties with my daughter I did
not want to do that 9:30 spot at the
store didn't wanna do it guys didn't
want to do it I had no choice I had no
[ __ ] choice I'd go down there follow
Eliza she [ __ ] destroyed the room I
had to go follow her I had a great time
seeing her I was home by 10:30 that's at
the point I didn't want to go 28 years
it's that time what when your mind tells
you not to do something that's what we
went back to January [ __ ] 3rd when
did the podcast resistance this is what
Steven tells you about resistance
resistance comes and every way whether
you gonna build the house like he said a
diet plan a career change anything that
requires us that anything that was gonna
make us better that's the [ __ ] that was
that's when resistance [ __ ] really
turns it up you know that's what
resistance really [ __ ] turns a peed
on you when you want to do something
that's gonna better your [ __ ] life so
you know I do things now listen the last
thing I want to do is lift weights
okay i'm mateus even enjoy it I'm an old
man I enjoy it but I'm an old [ __ ]
man
you know like I'm an old [ __ ] man
Mondays at 10 o'clock I lift weights and
went and Thursdays at 10 o'clock I live
weights why because I have to do it it's
part of the gate it's part of this gig
for me to go on the road I have to stay
healthy and for me this day health you
have to stay strong or for me to be
strong you gotta live [ __ ] weights
you know that's it I have to so I forced
myself to do all these things because I
know it's gonna make me that much better
I'm not better than anybody else I just
failed more than anybody else that's it
that's that's the basic truth and one
day you just tell yourself I'm not gonna
fail anymore or better yet I'm not gonna
fail at this I'm gonna fail a ton of
things but this I'm gonna work at like a
[ __ ] surgeon and when you want
something you know my niece is in
medical school she [ __ ] studies you
know she goes classes five hours a day
and then she studies probably hours at
that you know at 17 hours you know she
studies didn't she works like one hour
two hours at some [ __ ] lab in Jersey
or something like that she's 20 I was
trying to sleep you got all that energy
you know well I mean is there also a way
to look at it cuz look at what you said
earlier like her failure is not my
failure happens so when you think you're
not gonna fail is it also like coming
back from the failure like not letting
it be over cuz like in a way isn't
bombing failing but you come back you
could you die today right that day that
moment you failed for that moment
now when you really fail is if you go
home and quit and they would come back
on that stage right that's where you
fail when I fell off a horse I think
about
on the horse I failed as a cowboy but I
wasn't looking to be a cowboy either so
it didn't really matter to me but when
you fail at a business when you fail at
a venture when your idea fails doesn't
mean you're a [ __ ] failure that means
that you didn't think it out good enough
you didn't see this you weren't prepared
for it I failed as a father the first
time for years I was like I'm a [ __ ]
failure as a father I would listen to
fathers I would see guys like Josh wolf
I saw him as a father just it was [ __ ]
inspiring my upmost respect the Josh
wolf goes from what I see them go
through for ten years as a father by
himself a single dad I be indebted to
that man to give me a lesson in
character till the end I die whatever
you might think of Josh oh I don't like
comedy chaos out I don't give a [ __ ]
what you like here's I'm telling you
that that guy's got the character of a
[ __ ] a gentleman for what he did or
what he did with the kids especially
when they weren't his kids okay there
were his kids by marriage
they weren't they ain't come out of his
dick one of those kids came out of his
deck he took all three of them well I
saw Josh wolf that did that I would
snort coke every night because I was a
failure as a father hit josh is doing it
and doing comedy and doing everything
around it I couldn't even [ __ ] be a
father but I said to myself I took care
of his kids you know it always Sam
different podcasts like the care of his
kids and I was tight with Trevor who I
really love you know he's in the army
now he's old enough now but I was really
tight with the girl because I had a girl
I had a daughter so I went out of my way
to be extra special to that girl so
somebody could be extra special
my daughter she knows I have my legs
like that and that's why I am towards
most kids until I had my own daughter
you know I I failed but I knew I wasn't
a failure as a dad you follow me so this
guy he figured he just didn't fit in the
cracks of the Giants and then when he
went to the Jets maybe they had too many
of those guys the same position you know
just because you failed it doesn't mean
you're a failure it just didn't work out
that time now I could understand you're
ill feelings about not calling back and
wanting to do it I get it I did the same
thing I'm with you but something inside
you has to push you to go back that that
basketball thing stayed with me for a
[ __ ] long time me quitting and then I
quit karate when I was 16
another thing that was just unnecessary
quit unnecessary quit you know
unnecessary you know so now that in the
back of my mind that had made it alright
for me to quit things so I I don't want
to work in a warehouse I don't want to
cook I don't want to bartend I can't
tell you how much I want to bartend
couldn't tell you when I was 19 I had
this big [ __ ] plan of my bartending I
was in the revolutionized bartending I
had learned from my mother I had learned
from a school you know I was a people
person yeah I did great things as a
bartender but for all the bad [ __ ]
reasons if I was stuck at one restaurant
and said I'm gonna be a bartender with
the intentions of taking over the bar
staff and taking over the bar management
immense really being the GM I could have
done it and ran a great restaurant and
had good advertising and I know how to
get people to a bar you know it's funny
I was
calluses on my local years ago and I go
you want to run a bar you got a half
three hookers out of there you gotta go
and get three hookers yourself and go
can I talk to you for said I got this
bar listen I don't want a piece of your
action oh I'll let you drink there for
free just come in there every night
looking like you are there's some guy
comes up communal enough for action I'll
tell him me you want this and we'll cut
the deal right there than that that's
the first thing I got I got three broads
in there sucking dick just in case why
not
looking for another half of us being to
that it's a stool in case you're
visiting from out of town for the small
50 you gotta have a drug dealer in there
with you to drugs or not whether you do
drugs or not to get people to go to your
bar from Monday through Thursday there
better be a drug like the boxer yeah I'm
not saying it's a food court I went to a
bar and I went to a friend of Mines bar
in Jersey two years ago and I sat there
and this guy's on the up-and-up the guys
bar I went to I'm known him for 40 years
this guy's never touched a drug never
done nothing I drove all the way out to
you know welcome the bar and stuff I'm
sitting there watching him talking to
him and my brother George he drove me
out there and while we're talking I'm
seeing that this is like every other bar
in the country he's telling me how well
he's doing I'm watching the three chicks
behind the bar with their [ __ ] fake
tits
I'm watching the sports on the TV you
know I'm watching that he runs a happy
hour for certain beers um I see that he
has food he's doing all the right things
but I also saw I saw one guy go in and
out of the bathroom 25 times the other
guys that means there was somebody song
coke on the [ __ ] site that's a bar
yeah I guess what now I know this dude
40 years I know you know what I'm the
guy there I know that's not his guy I
know that he's worried about his liquor
license earliest nobody wants
coke so that you bought your Mallika
license if they even suspect you know
Yankee liquor license so but I know that
the bar can't exist without a coke deal
I know for you to have that Tuesday
through [ __ ] Thursday action there
Friday and Saturday people go out to
dates but I know Thursday through
[ __ ] Tuesday through [ __ ] Thursday
you gotta have somebody in there
slinging something otherwise you go to a
comedy store for example I go to the
Comi store I don't do cocaine
I don't do it not I want to do it I go
in there I think drink of water I sit in
the back i watch the two comics before
me I go on stage I go out and take a few
pictures I shake a few hands I sneaked
through the kitchen I get the [ __ ] out
of that if you asked me a year ago
I'll people don't cook at the Comedy
Store I look in the face cuz I'm sewing
I even tell you know I heard that after
I leave at about 11:30 that place
becomes [ __ ] narcos [ __ ] Mexicans
dropping off helicopters and [ __ ] say
you know when I was there buying coke
the dog I soaked up when I was there
he's long been gone right but do you
think it's do you know is it cuz you you
know what to look for for me a guy who's
never bought a coke in my life all I
know I might never see but I'm not
looking for it right I don't think
you're looking for a can you at least
recognize it if I see somebody lit yeah
I know it they're lit right I know I
don't let but I don't see any because
it's mine thirty when I'm done okay it's
10:15 it's 10:30
you know I get in the car it's 10:30
nobody's [ __ ] lit yet is there a
reason for that do you leave early on
purpose no no no I just leave early
because I gotta get up a sip of tea in
the morning with right wake up with a
kid that's the only reason why I leave
early I don't I don't I don't listen I
wouldn't care if somebody did drugs
around me and not I did so many drugs
how hypocritical will I be there's
somebody around me do drugs I tell my
comedian friends that they doing coke
and they're stuck in a plateau that they
should consider not doing coke no more
just look at what happened to me after I
stopped on coke my whole everything
changed I look from within I started
telling more stories you know I became a
little bit more active up on stage
little things I know that the cocaine
holds you back I don't give a [ __ ] what
anybody tells you
I know if you bring a Richard Pryor back
from the grave today as much as he liked
coke as much as I did LLL tell you
there's a big difference on stage and
you're doing coke and you're not don't
coke you know I hope Tennyson got
cleaned for a while before he died
I heard he was [ __ ] great it was two
different [ __ ] people you connect
more with your material your hearts not
blocked two drugs block your heart the
drugs block your heart certain drugs
block your heart my wall doesn't block
my heart from my stand-up when I would
do cocaine it would take away that he
manly from my stand-up it was like
computer the same material that's the
big difference I feel that's the
difference I feel since I haven't done
drugs and do comedy comics yeah I don't
think you're gonna say like people need
to do drugs to be a good comic but do
you think it like the mixture of
failures we're just getting over
something makes you a better work or a
person or I don't know good like it do
you think life's too easy and not to
have access these parts of you listen
then you gotta learn how to dig deep in
your life things are gonna happen in
your life parents dying you know animal
dies a lover a wife a good friend you
know you decide when you don't want to
fail anymore
you wake up one morning go you know what
life's gonna give me flat tires right
yeah batteries are gonna die right
people gonna cut you off Yeah right it's
gonna rain
powers are gonna go out hurricanes are
gonna happen
earthquakes these are all things I
cannot control I can't control this [ __ ]
I go in the car right now I go to switch
the car I go to I can't control that
that's not my fault
I can't control that I could control a
few things the M which is me and my
actions I can't control with you doing I
wish I could I wish I could tell people
you can't you can't control people
people don't nobody could when I was
being [ __ ] crazy
who was gonna control me people spoke to
me I took their word start I'm not gonna
lie to you and the older I got I took
better advice you know the older you get
you take better advice because you see
your family I am failing he's not lying
this guy's not lying to me this chick is
not lying to me what I'm not doing the
job you know you don't need jobs I had
that people came up to me like he's not
doing a good job like and I quit
whatever was something I wasn't into
when I install the gutters not gutters
uh and installed pipe for a while I
think I'd quit after three days like you
know sprinkler pipe okay and I keep that
[ __ ] I had it you had to dig like five
and three-quarter inches exactly I'm
like what's it do between five and three
quarters and six right inches think I
couldn't even give me an answer and him
and his wife would break my balls every
day I remember like it was yesterday
1983 this summer they broke I'm out this
wasn't my ass well they're like ah this
is five and three-eighths doesn't matter
just put the [ __ ] thing in then the
inspector came one day that's when it
really pissed me off he goes it wouldn't
it wouldn't hurt to be six inches and
the guys like yeah but about 10:00 at
night I don't like you know what you are
you're a sack of [ __ ] is what you are
right I'm on my hands and knees taking a
little patches of dirt putting the
little thing like if I'm gonna [ __ ]
Lego track here I'm on that [ __ ] show
building Legos that isn't
I don't know go [ __ ] myself after four
[ __ ] days you got me in here on my
hands and knees because it was six
inches did the [ __ ] blade is six
inches right so I would measure it from
the [ __ ] blade exactly he would come
and it doesn't have anything to do with
this what I'm telling you is I had
everything you know like I had all those
[ __ ] jobs I failed that you know
failing makes you [ __ ] tough failing
at different nobody's gonna [ __ ] hit
it big I wish they do
I wish anybody who sang a song on
YouTube made it big I wish it was that
easy well it's not that's why I love
people though I'm gonna make this video
go viral that's why right now I'm living
here 23 years I love when people tell me
I got a new agent what's that gonna do
me right let's say I do for you in
today's world and the way think I'm
gonna do nothing for you because you're
not going after it you have to go after
you have to get breakdowns you have to
sit there and look through the breakdown
and that's at 8:00 in the morning they
come out like the night before then they
keep coming out every couple hours see
you have to sit there as an actor on the
computer you're not supposed to get
those those are illegal
look people sell them to you you know
right you go to a [ __ ] agents
assistant and say Doug I need the
breakdown so I give you 200 a month what
boom yeah I have two breakdowns every
[ __ ] morning as soon as they get to
the office it's something that we've
talked about before but it's just I was
talking with Steve smart about it last
night because you said that failure
makes you stronger and it does but it
can also break you down and and I think
one of the hardest things is that it we
are growing up with feels like okay you
do something and then this happens and
it's over now as an adult you just keep
doing it you just have to keep forever
and there's no retirement like you have
to work out forever you have to look at
the breakdowns forever ever it's a
little it drags on what what if you got
an office job tomorrow
you have to do it forever what if you
became a cop
you got to do it forever that's why I
stress here don't go for money go for
what you love doing because you're gonna
have to do it forever so high for ever
everyday in a certain [ __ ] way you
know a certain way I have a friend
that's been a UPS since 1981 that was
the only job he's ever had in his whole
life is UPS started as a loader you know
the more failures you have the tougher
you become the tougher you become you
fall down you get up you fall down you
get up you try that joke it doesn't work
you write another one that one doesn't
work you write another one that one
doesn't work you write another one you
know you build the house the house Falls
[ __ ] it we build another one this one
hasn't held but the roof was [ __ ]
shaky you know you don't build the
perfect house the first time you know
that's why you use some of the
experience and then the more houses you
build you lose those people pretty soon
you're building houses and then when the
big thing is not to have a big enough
ego not to take advice from people
that's the problem that you have that
some people rather do something wrong
then ask for advice and do it right why
do it wrong do it right the first time
even though it's it's you know what I
listen that I'm doing Tommy I see what
birds doing the Tom Segura and Sebastian
are doing and Bill burr is doing and I'm
like maybe I'm doing something wrong I
know for a fact I'm doing wrong but I
guarantee the door is on the other hands
saying to himself maybe I'm doing
something wrong we all have a self doubt
yourselves doubt but it's also
interesting because you guys it seems
like at that level you guys have are all
doing the same thing but you do it a
little bit differently for
ever worked for you you this life has to
work for you you're playing this life on
home field it's your home field for
years you're playing away one day you
finally get to play at home field now
you got to figure out how to play at
home every week it's tacit to what works
for you that's it it has to work for you
it has to make you happy it has to work
out for your family what you do affects
every little piece of everything that
happens you know it has to work for you
if I was 29 right now not married no
mercy no podcast and I was selling
comedy clubs out never mind theatres you
wouldn't see me in this town he's been I
won't all had to be on the road every
Thursday Friday Saturday leave Wednesday
night I would not take date o'clock
flight back on Sunday morning I would
take the six o'clock flight back get
here at midnight sleep all day Monday
and do it all over again
I would probably take December in
January off and I would work those other
[ __ ] whatever weeks because that's
what I'm allowed to do I don't have a
responsibility I do not have to be here
everybody has different things
guess what Bert has two daughters Bert
likes going out heavy on big heavy tours
you know it's a party for Bert that
works for Bert you know Tom those little
tours he was in this weekend Christine
is out for a few weeks
you know they switch so you have to make
it work for you but I'm not even talking
about Tommy I'm talking about even life
you know I work on this [ __ ]
warehouse Joey you know I don't do
nothing at night then work nights and
have you date you rather be off
date-time you rather be on an 80-degree
[ __ ] water work [ __ ] night step it
work from home now there's a lot of jobs
you can work on home there's so many
different options that you have both
that's what we're talkin about
it's like right now you're always
playing on the away one day you play on
your field it takes time to get life to
be on your playing field once you get it
on your playing field now you have to
keep it there that's the secret knowing
what to do once you get there I can't
wait to be a headliner I can't wait to
be a master electrician I can't wait to
own my own bar and then you get there
and you fail because you weren't
prepared for that
you would just focused on getting there
you didn't think about what you were
gonna do when you got there
or you didn't II thought you knew it's
time I'm just gonna buy a [ __ ] bar
and have a [ __ ] great time no yeah no
you gotta [ __ ] measure the shots no
you gotta see what you profit to [ __ ]
be a ratio is you let's see what your
busy times are this isn't just a [ __ ]
party and that's what a lot you know I
always bring Houston up Houston comedy
number one the country [ __ ] best open
mikes best everything for years the
problem was it was too much of a party
and when comics went down there the top
comics they would lose their mind for
six days like birth nuts he loses his
[ __ ] mind like I would do for six
days
I wouldn't go to sleep fly her Birds out
you know my goal was to go get kolache
Xan eight snort coke try Google kolache
today and I have no responsibilities you
know that you could only do that for so
[ __ ] long and then things start
happening and then you start getting
sick so you have to make these little
adjustments in your life no matter what
it is you know how hard it is for a guy
was trying to raise a family that all of
a sudden gets sick and he has to tell
his job he can't work that many hours a
week you know I
for me right now at my age if you're
paying to come see me on the week i'm
mateus up whether it's the late show the
second show I'm gonna give you [ __ ]
everything I got
I'm gonna give you everything I [ __ ]
got I can't do that if I do that
Wednesday through Saturday by the time
you see me Friday night I'm gonna be dog
[ __ ] I'm gonna be honestly if you see
I'm coming to your town and I worked at
Wednesday
don't even bother Payne the mother you
come see me at least I'm honest with ya
I'm gonna be dog [ __ ] because I'm 57
this doesn't work for me no more you
know what two shows on a Friday and two
shows on the Saturday work for me just
great they great when I go to Tempe
Valentine's Day I do that Thursday I'll
be fine
just how to do radio I get up like I
stay up late by work I'll have a friend
to work out with my buddy owns [ __ ]
10th planet Phoenix you know whatever
down there so yeah I got different
options but the Wednesday through Sunday
[ __ ] Sunday you really want to come see
me Sunday you're gonna see pure [ __ ]
you're gonna see somebody going through
the [ __ ] motions why because I'm not
trying I know more but guess what I know
this so agents call me and say hey do
this no because I won't be able to cover
the spread for those people on this I'm
doing a tricky weekend man and people
are worried look like what why are you
doing this you never do this because I
know I could do it because I have
nothing else before that and nothing
else after that for a long [ __ ] time
it's kind so it's like like now you see
it's not that you don't forget feel but
you notice we're failures failures are
and you avoid it so if I was gonna
working some of that's that's a failure
when I was not when I took all those
free economic classes I learned a lot I
finally got to take those economic
classes and figure them out into life
it's the same thing in life you know
with with employees you know
what how when you look at an employee
when you have a tire shop okay I mean
your tire shop is open six to six that's
a 12-hour [ __ ] day
yeah we young we could do that [ __ ] six
days a week in fact I did it six days a
week I could work that [ __ ] six days a
week I could work at seven [ __ ] days
a week but then in time you're gonna see
that as you get older that sign but
you're still gonna do it because your
family needs the money your family is
the money you never put away money your
family needs the money or whatever
how good is an employee like you have to
decide on like our friend Bob alingas
he's an accountant great church family I
don't want him working eleven hour days
cuz after eight hours he's gonna be
giving away my [ __ ] money's money
right he's gonna be paying bills aren't
even [ __ ] do he's seen so many
[ __ ] numbers show everybody hat
everybody has a different thing that
they could do some people have six hours
you know if you have a computer from
today and I don't and I hire you lease I
have to be a data entry guy are you
really gonna be putting data entry in
eight hours a day not really oh yeah you
listen to Tom Segura you listen to Joey
Diaz you listen to Bill burr you listen
to NPR
you're watching [ __ ] Schulz videos
right Matt shows videos Andrew Schulz
videos you're looking at an old Patrice
O'Neal video you're looking at a [ __ ]
Mitch Hedberg video bottom line I really
got you for five [ __ ] hours yeah so
why am I gonna beat you follow me so now
I learned that you know what I'm gonna
hire these guys for six hours they're
gonna work five days a week gonna work
30 hours not gonna qualify to get
insurance because they still gonna be
part-time
you know there's no overtime there
because I'm gonna bring another shift in
that [ __ ] twelve to work till eight I
want my guys fresh you always want you
guys freshening when you have these
fires you have these firemen that go
into like two days
sleeping god bless their hearts but the
longer that they're tired the the more
[ __ ] can happen the more little mistakes
can happen they could fall off a cliff
they could fall onto a roof that's not
secured so with me with calm me now I
know exactly what I can do you know next
don't wanna Tempe guess what I'm doing
to show us the store this Sunday night
I'm not going on next Tuesday ok ok yeah
it ought to be Thursday night I want to
be ready for so I already have it
planned out already I look at my month
and I can tell you what I'm gonna be
doing March hadn't moved my braid dates
to June cuz I'm shooting some movie so I
had to move that one date for March
whatever to June 4th through the 7th
so my March is gonna be really [ __ ]
easy so my April could be a little
heavier but this year if you look at my
schedule it's gonna be light although I
thought about August then August
December we'll going off I'm going off
big time you know and I rest in job they
call it January off and it's just it's
it's nice hearing it from someone
because yeah like especially now for me
I I have to but I'm in the mode where I
take every gig I get offered because I
wanna I want a choice but but it at a
certain point will a certain point I'll
be hopefully in a similar position to
you headlining can use but you have to
turn off like you have to adjust and be
like ok you don't take everything now I
met you I met my wife at that's 20 years
ago that means I was doing stand-up 7
years when I met her I got her involved
in my stand-up I let her get involved
before that I would argue with her and
bang heads with her I let her get
involved in like 208 and everything
changed ok I let her get involved in 208
and everything changed because she
stopped me from being a [ __ ]
I was talking about common friend of
mine yeah then I said told me it's time
for you to start listening to your wife
more because warhorse
once you become a comic you become a
[ __ ]
like the man said if Isis started as
early but I would call your agent
tomorrow yeah if I told you right now
trust me I know people do it I know
people tape the people if Isis started a
streaming service that's the [ __ ] we
are living in LA as comics actors
writers were [ __ ] [ __ ] that's why
you have to get somebody opposite you
that's not a [ __ ] that'll say to you
that deal ain't worth it that's not
worth it that's not worth it but by 2008
I already have five movies under my belt
I had 10 TV shows under my belt you know
I already had a CD I didn't have to do
this [ __ ] I was doing I could turn stuff
down you're in no position to turn
anything down right a roller skating
rink that they're Russian they're not
gonna understand you you still go there
whether they're paying you or not it's a
set and right now all you're looking for
is sets you know I've done plenty of
movies I don't agree with it I don't
agree with it I don't agree with me
doing a 12 hour movie and your
apprenticeship is you're working for
free that's not my game at all
I'm never gonna agree that for anybody
in my world no I don't want anybody
working for free in my world never but
it's good to do once in a while it's
good to do from time for standup it's
just an hour it's just ten minutes she's
doing for free it's somebody doing 24
hours hey whatever then we gotta pay but
in the beginning you know I always knew
there was no money I wanted to fall in
love with it at first there's an
intimate detail I want to talk about
about somebody but I can't when I bathed
this girl in the beginning because of
everything I had done before I didn't
have that much sex when I was my wife
that's why our relationship lasted
because I didn't make it about sex I
made it about us having a bond at first
I didn't make it about us having great
sex everybody gets married after they
have great sex and they realize they
don't have a [ __ ] bond right yeah you
can have great sex with a [ __ ] donkey
you know that pussy's tied enough and
she warms up her lips you don't know
what you dick will feel like I'm saying
I mean I'm not saying I'm gonna have
[ __ ] sex with donkey I'm just saying
that we sell are we judge our [ __ ]
love by how good the [ __ ] is but she's
a failure has a [ __ ] woman
she sleeps all day she don't get up she
won't get a job she don't clean you got
fruit flies your kids go to school dirty
but she sucks a dick for a half hour she
puts a lighter on me and nutsack and
that freaks you out so that's why you
stay with it right we makes it you know
men make men and women make bad without
the decisions because of the sex and
guess who made a bunch of those me you
know a girl would suck your balls I'm
marrying that [ __ ] thank God and
maariyah but yeah I was like that I was
shallow like the hair I was very sure
mindset yeah it's a mindset when I met
my wife I made sure that our
relationship wasn't based on sex at
first I would take her for coffee and
then drop her office she would look at
like you're not coming up not really
yeah because I want and she even asked
me I told but like that the eight month
mark I explained her why we're doing
this
and she was like oh okay and then yeah
that erupted in the midst of having sex
there it was happy but I really wanted
to fall in love with somebody yeah
something that we don't do naturally we
forgotten because everything of mine is
about the instant [ __ ] the hook-up that
is to that wouldn't it just be nice to
talk to some mind be great for coffee
really
have fun with some money what was last
time you were with somebody really
genuine that you really really really
enjoy them because what good is the
[ __ ] if once you start talking I'm
going to put a gun in my mouth yeah that
girl watch whatever home was you wanna
stick a gun in your mouth her milkshake
door and it's uh that then describes I
mean obviously need to lose weight but
I'm not even I could date right now but
that's that is exactly why I don't is
the idea the idea of going through like
and having that nothing they're bad
people but just they're not for me
like we're not for each other and I'm
sure girls have been on dates be like
Jesus Christ what is he talking about
like that whole process is awful awful
just like I don't want to put myself
through it awful it's an awful process
but since you were saying it you know we
have just talked about it that's what uh
this podcast la just made me realize
that I had a really gopher at the age of
twenty seven when I got at halfway house
and I want to wish my daughter happy
30th even though she doesn't want to
speak to me anymore what are you gonna
do I have accepted it I've moved on it
was you know she's judging me by the boy
that I used to be not the man I became
so [ __ ] everybody I'm saying I do this
to make my friends happy I want my the
people around me to be happy and most
importantly I want to be happy and
that's it and I hope this podcast helps
you out in one way or another we always
start the first of the month with just
us just to [ __ ] get out some [ __ ]
some people like it some people don't go
[ __ ] yourself I'm the Captain Kirk for
this [ __ ] enterprise or
understand me
don't forget February 13th through the
15th Tempe improv next weekend and then
February 28th I'm a treasure
[ __ ] Island would deem Dell
Rizzi for one night only it's a Friday
night it's the 28th or 29th
go look at the [ __ ] calendar and
choose for yourself that's all I got in
February like I said I keep it slow
because I want to give you the best
shows everything at the store I could
get a spot destroy every night okay I
play it safe you're coming from [ __ ]
England to see me I don't want to eat a
bag of dicks in front of you
right give them saying I'm gonna eat a
bag of dicks from time to time I think I
did last Tuesday one of those nights
you're saying it too rough sense yeah
two rosettes and that's happens but if I
went to the store every night I
guarantee bombs three nights bomb three
times because you're doing seven sets
you're gonna go 50% 60% I'm just playing
percentage these guys I just play
percentages oh you know I think out of
all the places I did last year I bombed
them like three I know I bombed in New
Orleans I know I bombed them all of the
shows and San Fran you know it just
doesn't go your way but you do the more
shows we do the more you bomb but the
better you get you see them saying what
some was set back you know it's also you
know when I was a roofer yeah I can't
family roots ended on fire when we were
doing hot tar roof oh my god my mistake
I don't know what I'm doing that's why I
didn't like [ __ ] hot tar roofs I like
ballasted roofs with rocks and [ __ ] once
I had to do that hot [ __ ] that was not
for me that [ __ ] was not for me those
things will blow up fly you normally how
many Mexicans I see burn for that hard
[ __ ] like that cuz they're always always
Mexicans get burnt everything cuz
they're by them [ __ ] machine the
thing blows up yeah I don't know I'm all
right man I'm just trying to put the
pieces together just try to I'm just
trying to [ __ ] and stay alive it oh
please because you got to put that hard
tire on and then I can't tell you how
many of those machines went on fire when
I was on the roof that walk away
sometimes one time I just flew down the
ladder like what are you doing is a fire
up thick well but there were five
English
like a [ __ ] guy with a [ __ ] dog
with spots client no [ __ ] fireman I'm
not going up there
what might I do I don't know nothing
about fire and that's it I'm happy you
guys listen today I want to wish my
daughter a happy birthday Jackie D as
she calls herself something else now
what are you gonna do what her name is
Jackie Dee's I wish her happy birthday
and I hope you guys got something out of
my story today I didn't have much to
tell you
but whatever it is keep hanging in there
don't give up don't quit it's not worth
the aggravation unless it's worth quite
a lot of things that's worth quitting
but the most important thing I wasn't
gonna quit I didn't quit and I'm very
proud of that today again I'll see you
in Tempe next weekend and tuition then
I'll see you at beautiful Treasure
Island in Las Vegas I love you guys have
a great day
we'll be back Thursday morning tip-top
[ __ ] Magoo
stay black have a good day I love you